when you're done
you got something okay how are you doing
okay
hmm
luncheons
i'm just saying like maybe it's over
maybe they haven't come there
everybody hello what's going on
uh
i'll come to you and then
i'm here
yes yep there's one voiceover here's one
on the
after they speak a speech to a joint
meeting in congress by the irish
t-shock in 96 that i just within the
past six months i found
afterwards and i'm taking calls yeah
that's what i heard i heard you doing
calling one i get that
crazy when you were
yeah i just started running into this
stuff yeah yep
it doesn't bother me
right
turn
is
okay right now
or gallery
okay
oh yeah
yes
um
and he was pretty good
question
okay
what i was surprised
even though she
the first time
this world's different
is
is
hey guys two minutes thank you so much
okay
they live on that phone
okay
thank you
you hear me
where's richard j durbin
what is the j i don't even know joseph
yussel as they say in brooklyn
any of you ever hear of yasel
there you go
she thought it was noodles well that's
close i think
i think there's something like noodles
that has a similar word
all right good afternoon everybody and
thank you for
joining us i want to thank our great
leadership team of
durban murray and stabenow for joining
us as well
now we had a very good virtual caucus
meeting
an hour ago we're all energized by the
opportunities that are ahead
with the new senate majority our entire
caucus agrees
we must have big strong bold action
to deal with this crisis for the six
last six years leader mcconnell and the
republicans turned the senate into a
legislative graveyard
now that leader mcconnell has relented
on his demand
that was preventing the senate from
moving forward with an organizing
resolution
we can begin work to help the american
people get out of this crisis
and make america bigger and better and
stronger
and as i've been saying all along the
senate will deal with
three things simultaneously nominations
we're working to confirm more nominees
this week
a fair impeachment trial and delivering
emergency covert relief
we want to work with our republican
colleagues to advance this legislation
in a bipartisan way
but the work must move forward
preferably with our republican
colleagues
but without them if we must time
is of the essence to address this crisis
we're keeping all options open on the
table
including using budget reconciliation
the first step to pursuing covert relief
legislation through reconciliation would
be to pass a budget resolution
and so in keeping our options open
on our caucus call today i informed
senators to be prepared
that a vote on a budget resolution could
come as early
as next week senator yassell
it's a year ago it was a year ago this
week
that the first coronavirus patient was
diagnosed in my state of illinois
one year she traveled to china came back
to the suburbs of chicago and was
diagnosed with coven 19.
that's the first we saw it in our state
a year later
one million people in my state have been
infected by the covet 19 virus
and 19 000 have died that happened in
one
year we have not won this war yet
against this
covet 19 or this pandemic we're in a
situation
politically though where some people
would like to think we have
those would be the same people would say
you know d-day was so successful we
don't have to continue this war do we
quarterbacks who say can we end this in
the third quarter that'll be just enough
for me
well that doesn't reflect reality we
still have a battle to fight here
go home and ask people how how much
access they have to vaccines
patty has been a leader on this issue
and people don't i can tell you in my
hometown in springfield illinois
calling the sangman county health
department trying to find a day when you
can get a vaccination
even for eligible groups is 50 50
whether you even get through
and that's the reality of what we faced
with in terms of these vaccines
what president biden has said is we need
to get serious about this and now
if we're not deadly serious about this
then this is going to be a deadly
pandemic
much much longer and that means moving
now ending the debate and moving forward
with passing legislation to extend
the vaccines and to make sure that more
and more of them are being produced
that isn't the end of it we have so many
thousands of people in my state
350 000 claiming unemployment benefits
190 000 pandemic
unemployment assistance and 210 000
pandemic emergency unemployment
compensation
these people don't have anywhere to turn
and if we're going to cut off
our benefits to them it's fundamentally
unfair to these families
i was in on the ground floor of the
so-called
common sense caucus 908 caucus
bipartisan caucus senators
and the reason we came up with the bill
we did and gave it to the leaders
to complete in december was we said this
is an emergency bill affecting the first
quarter of the year
so what are going to do about the rest
of it that's what president biden is
challenging us to do
is to make sure that we do about do
something about the rest of the year in
terms of improving the economy
the cash payments for families we can
have a a good argument as to
the exact formula and i think we should
but the bottom line is these families
are desperate for financial assistance
and they need it now
i'm just going to close i'm not the
economist and the expert in the subject
but someone who is janet yellen said
without further action
we risk a longer more painful recession
now and longer term scoring
of the economy later we've got to help
the american families across the board
get vaccinated
get this pandemic behind us and get back
to work
well thank you oh murray we know that
much
is that another kind of noodle or one
thank you it is very clear that our
to-do list is really long but we are
finally in a position to start
acting on it families and communities
are reeling from this public health and
economic devastation that
covet 19 has caused rather than
downplaying this crisis or dismissing
the struggle people are experiencing
experiencing we are going to deliver on
direct payments
child care vaccines critically important
getting our kids back into classrooms
helping our state local and tribal
governments respond
to coba 19 without having to cut jobs
and further undermine our local
economies and much more we're going to
fight for paid sick leave
and raising the minimum wage to 15 an
hour as senator
sanders and i and our house colleagues
laid out this morning
we're also going to be moving to make
sure that the biden harris
administration's nominees
are able to get to work on the massive
challenges
ahead of us and we will be ready to hold
former president trump accountable for
his role
in citing the january 6 insurrection to
make clear
we reject his and others attempts
to allow brute force to win over
democracy
in this country our to-do list is long
and it is ambitious because it has to be
given all that we face
i'd also like to note that everyone in
our country is struggling with this
pandemic
everyone every family benefits from
having the biden harris administration
complete
and able to tackle challenges like
public health work education and more
in this moment every citizen should be
able to
trust their elected officials will stand
up for their right
to have their vote counted rather than
overruled by a violent mob
so after the last two weeks of
unnecessary delay we will continue to
urge our republican colleagues to work
with rather than against us in this
incredibly
difficult pivotal moment for our country
but i also want to be clear we are going
to get things done
and most importantly what i'd like
families in my home state of washington
and nationwide
to hear today is this we know how
difficult things are
we're going to get to work fast thank
you and
i'll turn it over to senator stephanie
well thank you very much i'm afraid of
what senator schumer's name is
i don't know i don't know but well
i'm i'm so pleased to be here with our
senate leadership team and i have to say
it's an exciting moment
as we turn the page with president biden
and
vice president kama harris and a new
democratic majority in the senate in the
house
four years ago when the republicans came
in in this
same time 2017 they made it very clear
what
who their priority was very clear they
moved forward full speed on budget
retaliation to
push through a two trillion dollar tax
cut
for the wealthiest and most
well-connected people
in the country we have a different
priority
a different set of folks that we care
about
we care about everybody else who wasn't
included in that picture
working families folks in the middle
class folks trying to get in the middle
class people who are poor
low wealth americans who have been left
behind and yet have been the ones at the
front of this crisis
working when we didn't have to we're
zooming
their essential workers and people over
and over again who've been
impacted by this crisis so what
president has proposed what we are
working on in support is to robustly
and quickly help everyone
both have their capacity to be healthy
and save lives and be able to
get our arms around this so everyone can
get a vaccine
and also to focus on people's
livelihoods
every life has been turned upside down
let's face it
everybody's and we understand
that we have got people who need to have
not only their job
their small business their farm but
children have got to go back to school
all of these things need to happen so we
in america
can get back to living our lives in a
safe
way and give everybody a fair shot
to succeed in our country that's what
we're about
and we're going to work our hearts out
to get that done
thank you my colleagues we're going to
have to be quick today because we have
to be on the floor at 2 30. um
working more days will there be more
amendment votes than there have been in
the past
i know part of the 2000 agreement was
not to build an amendment tree for the
two leaders
um how do you expect the senate we hope
we can get a more open
process under leader mcconnell it's been
totally closed
we've hardly done any legislating the
house sent over 260 some odd bills and
none of them saw the light of day
we want to have a more open process our
number one goal
we have to get big bold things done both
to deal with covet
and to deal with the underlying crises
in america such as climate such as
economic and racial inequality such as
making our democracy more perfect that
is our number one goal
and we will try to work the senate so
much more is accomplished than what did
than when uh
mcconnell was leader yes
sounds like you're gonna move very
quickly on reconciliation like
possibly do you have to pick all 50 of
your democratic
senators who would support
reconciliation and the contents
of that look we haven't even seen the
details of the bill yet so obviously
that's a premature question
but i think our caucus is united in that
we need big bold change
in 2013 with the nuclear option
democrats said no we're not going to go
down that road the filibuster
will still be here 10 months later they
open the door on nuclear option one can
you
number one guarantee that in 10 months
that won't be the case and how do you
explain
to those who are pushing uh the
democrats to get rid of the filibuster
that we can't do that
right now how do you bottom line is very
simple we are united in that we need
big bold change in america and we will
figure out the best way to get that done
next you've got several new members of
your caucus how do you suggest they get
ready for impeachment what should they
be reading and what should they be doing
well they can study the previous trials
and see how the procedures
operated but i think that this one
what hap the american people were
witness to what happened
we all were witness to what happened and
uh
so you don't need to uh delve into
details of things you don't know as much
because so much of it was clear
and um look to me what trump did was the
most despicable thing
any president has ever done i believe he
should be convicted
yes um senator prime administration has
laid out obviously
an ambitious agenda on immigration and
climate and other issues
they seem to have been open to
potentially breaking some of those
things down instead of one larger
package
that's something that you might consider
i read that in the paper today i haven't
had any discussions with them about that
at this point
we're focused on getting a good covert
bill done
last one have you given thought to
how long it needs to last what witnesses
you'd like we're still we're still
we're still negotiating on the trial
with uh leader mcconnell so far the
negotiations have worked out pretty well
um we came to an agreement that met our
needs and his he needed some time
for the trump lawyers to prepare we
wanted time to do
uh uh covet and nominations um let's
hope it continues along that vein
last one leader you said that you want
to have a bipartisan
deal and that you want to see what the
details are in the package before you
talk about things
like reconciliation how long are you
willing to wait
on republicans to come to the table and
negotiate something before you go down
like we have to we have to see what they
say in the next few days some of the
comments admittedly have been
disheartening
some of them have rejected rejected
things right now but we're always
hopeful
that some of them will see the light and
remember
even on reconciliation republicans can
join us and vote for it that's happened
many times in the past
thank you everybody
bigfoot
can't hear you
[Music]
you